what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime uproar and I am back at it
again to discuss the latest insane
chapter of One Piece just want to let
you all know that our boy goes and is
recovering well and he wants to extend
his thanks and how grateful he is for
all your get well soon messages and me
too actually it's been so nice to see
all your love and support for our boy in
the comments section he will be back
very very soon so this chapter had some
very interesting things happen within it
such as the reveal of vegapunk's devil
fruit more information on the giant
ancient Golem the Revolutionary Army
makes an appearance and more so make
sure to stay tuned for that now if you
do enjoy these one piece videos on the
channel you know what to do smash that
like button as it really helps us out
with that YouTube algorithm if you
haven't already make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future wampy's chapters reviews and
updates and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all
so chapter 1067 was entitled Punk
records and man do we find out some a
very interesting things about what this
is now the cover story for this chapter
shows sees a clown and judge reuniting
with some of the German siblings in the
background it does look like there is
some sort of incident going down here as
the two look to be arguing about
something so I do look forward to seeing
what comes next of that now into the
chapter itself we start off exactly
where we left off in the last chapter
with the real vegapunk and Luffy's group
Bonnie asks vegapunk what happened to
his head wasn't it larger like a light
bulb which yeah it was when we saw
vagapunk in the last chapter on O'Hara
where he met Dragon it was a feature
that was definitely you know unmissable
even Dragon made a comment on the size
of his head so the question is has
Bonnie pointed out what happened to his
head so so vegapong replies by saying
that it had grown quite large so I cut
it Bonnie screams you can't just cut it
like cutting hair and you know what I'm
with her here imagine that for a second
oh my head is getting long again I'll
just get it trimmed down a bit for the
summer outrageous outrageous stuff here
but you know what I do like that I
thought it was pretty cool so the
conversation continues as
we met last time my body size grew large
just like a Giants to which jinbei says
I've heard rumors that he's a large guy
fagerpunk then reveals to us that he is
a brainiac who ate the nomi nomi fruit
aka the brain brain fruit and with that
he can remember every tiny detail of
knowledge the more knowledge that
vegapunk gains the more his brain grows
in size getting bigger and bigger with
the data capacity not only that but he
was already born as a genius with
unlimited data Bank in its brain prior
to eating the nomi nomi fruit that's
just absolutely insane so he is born a
genius and then also gains the power of
the nomi nomi devil fruit those two
things combined make him the most like
op when it comes to knowledge his stats
in that field are like absolutely tanked
that's for sure vegapun continues in a
glorified manner to say that his brain
has grown into the world's largest brain
and yet it still continues to grow I
gotta say what I like that comes next is
the two very different reactions that
come from characters whose responses are
you know really so true to their
characters personalities Chopper is in
absolute awe of this information and
wants to know more he says that is
incredible as a researcher are you
strong too Dr vegapong twitch vagapunk
is like yeah of course I am of course
because because of course it would be
the other response comes from Luffy and
it's hilarious he asks old man you cut
your head does that mean you became an
idiot to be absolutely fair to Luffy
here it is it's like a very simplistic
way of thinking but he isn't wrong in
his question here Luffy logic makes 100
sense to me right here Vega Punk however
did not appreciate Luffy's logic as he
says not to underestimate my genius you
brat killer stuff right here absolutely
love it so what happened to the brain
that he had cut well he tells the guys
that the apple on his head is actually
an antenna and that at the top of the
island on the back side of the Giant Egg
the words Punk records are written on it
it turns out that the joint egg is the
hanger for his giant brain he continues
to say that even if he is apart from it
the antenna will connect vagapunk to the
data via psychic waves so he can access
all that knowledge at any time that he
pleases so what we're saying here is
that vegapunk basically turned his brain
into an iCloud or like a giant Google
Drive that he can access wherever he
wants one of my first questions was you
know was there a distance limit on the
antenna as to where he couldn't connect
if he was too far away which of course
leads to events later in the chapter or
if those psychic waves essentially act
as an internet connection to his iCloud
brain that he can access if he has clear
signal I I don't know but uh let me know
what you guys think
anyway he continues by asking the group
earlier you guys met with a girl named
vegapunk right he explains about the
other vegapunks we have seen and say
that they were his clones there are six
of them on this island now I just loved
the little Naruto reference here as
Luffy says is that a ninja move when
these series reference or like nod to
another in these small ways it's just
great and you absolutely love to see it
so vegapunk continues to say that each
of them is an expert in a certain field
of course as we knew as viewers already
all six of them share the same
personality as me but the labor force is
that of six people vegapon continues to
say that once a day he synchronizes
their experience and knowledge through
Punk records each one of their
personalities and Duties are separate
but each of their experiences is
worthwhile so not only has he turned his
brain into an iCloud or Google drive but
he has also made it a shared drive too
or maybe he has basically just turned
his brain into Google so vagapon
continues to say consider it like using
the same library for example if every
person in the world can access my brain
it's as if all mankind has acquired my
knowledge also if mankind reciprocally
can update the punk records it is
possible to create a sea of knowledge
far beyond my brain this brain will
someday be shared with mankind jimbei
asks if there will be any inconvenience
if you get into my thoughts to which
vagapunk replies by saying you are a
sharp one Knight of the sea jinbei but
science cannot move forward if you worry
about that
so in all this is really interesting and
it also makes me think that egg Island
and vegapunk would be a huge Target for
the world government if they were to
like find out about this imagine all
that knowledge that he has collected
especially on things that they
definitely don't want the general public
finding out about and then we've got
vegapunk freely going to give access to
all of this information to all of
mankind it does seem like this could get
pretty dangerous to me but I respect
what vegapunk is doing here A True True
scientist Bonnie has well and truly had
enough and says you never change
vagapunk you're willing to sacrifice for
the sake of science that's why you
transformed my father into an
emotionless combat weapon she then pulls
out the jungling Slayer 3000 on vegapunk
and is literally about to go full 66 on
him Bonnie's rage is of course
understandable here but it's outbursts
could come with some dire consequences
the other shout out to her Bonnie please
think again if you kill him you will end
up making more enemies than you could
imagine this is a very true statement
here as there are seemingly different
parties linked to vagapunk who would
Mark Bonnie as a Target if she were to
kill him think about it you've got the
other vagapunks possibly the straw hats
themselves and you know the
Revolutionary Army is another
possibility either way the lightsaber
doesn't have the function Bonnie thinks
it does as Vega Punk yells out that the
beams function is actually to attract a
large number of insects at which time a
large amount of insects are like drawn
to the blade and sworn Bonnie which
leads to her passing out don't blame
this leading her to pass out by the way
now I'm not the worst when it comes to
Insects but if a large number was
hurling down on my sorry self let's just
say I do a lot more than pass out that's
for sure now what I do like about this
situation is how Luffy talks to the
passed out Bonnie saying oi Bonnie look
what I found a large stag beetle it just
reminds me of like the earliest guy Pier
days vegapunk after suffering a
near-death experience does agree that
her reason to kill him makes sense and
that he was only saved because the
lightsaber was a failed product which
leads him to asking Luffy that they
recently went to wano right was it true
that there was another Dragon there
besides kaido himself the dragon in
question is of course mermanosuke Luffy
says Oh you mean Momo vegapong says it's
a failed devil fruit that I had left in
Punk Hazard it seems he ate it Luffy
asks if it was really a failed product
vegapunk explains that it was an
artificial devil fruit that he had
created with a large amount of research
funds over 20 years that was made from
kaido's lineage but his growth won't be
the same as the original Fruit Luffy is
like ah so that's why he can turn into a
dragon like kaido but it was a success
he can spit fire and he is powerful even
now he became a guardian deity for wano
completely agree with Luffy here by the
way the fruit really did seem to have
worked and let us not forget the hype
here that Luffy considers mominosuke a
guardian deity of wano alongside Yamato
that's awesome so why is this devil
fruit a failed product if it seemed to
work with the only flaw being that its
growth wouldn't be the same as kaido's
well it's minor and it speaks to the
perfectionist that vegapunk is turns out
that it was a failed product in
vegapung's eyes due to the fact that he
didn't like the color in which the fruit
turned out he asked Luffy what the color
of the fruit was in which Luffy replies
pink and then vegapug falls to his knees
in defeat crying out you see it was a
great failure Luffy is like I mean it
still works though to which jinbei says
ah I see he is a genius and a
perfectionist now our attention is then
moved on to the giant ancient row robot
as Luffy asks vegapunk how about this
robot please move it aren't you the one
who created it vagapong replies by
saying no that's wrong that's the
legendary metal giant that attacked
marijua 200 years ago the group are
shocked by it being 200 years ago as
vagapon continues to say also that
machine was probably created far more
than 900 years ago he continues to say I
still don't know the reason for its
creation I heard there was damage due to
the lack of energy the researchers at
the time were surprised with the unknown
signs that it has no one knows where it
came from or what it was trying to do so
we got some interesting information on
this robot here as of course we know
this thing is very old ancient even
which of course ties it to the ancient
Kingdom of way back when the other
interesting thing is how vegapunk
mentioned its lack of energy what
exactly was used to power this ancient
Giant and could that energy be
reproduced in our time to to make it
work again and help us find out you know
more information and answer to the
questions that we have I do think maybe
joyboy could be involved here and the
sun god nicer Powers he had that could
be a potential source of its power and
that would line up very nicely with
Luffy now being here on the island as
someone who could have the power to get
this thing up and running again what do
you guys think about this ancient giant
let us know your theories in the
comments section below vagapon continues
to give the group more information on
the giant as he tells us that the world
government had ordered its complete
destruction however the Curiosity of the
research has led them to not carrying
out the order it still exists here
because the information on it has been
passed down from generation to
generation the government didn't know
about its existence he says to the group
that you guys did well coming here you
must have seen the entrance as a wall
right Luffy's like oh yeah well I did go
rough on it and chop says no know we
just got lost we did not go rough on it
to which vagapong says well I'm truly
sorry for that experience
so here we have the government slipping
up again here like they did with O'Hara
I mean if you're going to order someone
to destroy this ancient giant from over
900 years ago you certainly wouldn't
task this with researchers whose
curiosity and thirst for knowledge would
compel them to keep the robot for
Science and information over destroying
it completely this move from the world
government certainly didn't make sense
to me thus the continued existence of
said giant it will be very interesting
if the government do learn that the
giant is still in existence however so
we go back to Shaka and the others and
the thing he wanted to show the guys was
the same ancient robot that the real
vegapunk is showing Luffy and Co Robin
says 200 years ago that is the exact
year when the discrimination against the
fish men started Frankie says so that
robot climbed through the red line and
Shaka says probably now I was kind of
hoping that what Shaka wanted to reveal
them was going to be something different
so we would have like two different big
reveals going on but it does make a lot
of sense that he would be showing them
the robot as he was talking about the
void Century in the last chapter to them
maybe I was being greedy and wanted more
of that juicy Intel but to be honest I
am fine with this Shaka continues in
saying we created Vega Force One based
on everything we learned from it but
there are things that I can't replicate
with my science Frankie is shocked to
hear Shaka say that there is a machine
that even they can't replicate to which
Shaka says the problem is power in the
past there was the power that was enough
to change the common sense of the world
today the others are just happy to see
that Luffy and the others are okay as
they see them through the cameras or
monitors in this point but they ask who
the girl is that is with them and of
course it's our boy Sanji Who would know
the exact identity of the girl who was
with them as he says it's jewelry body
right she's a pirate just like us it
just for me it had to be Sanji to know
who the female pirate was yeah I love
that detail uh that it was him he's just
a man of my own heart I love that guy so
much anyway so we go back to the real
vegapunk who admits that he had done
some bad things to Bonnie to which Luffy
says oh yeah old man you should beg for
forgiveness vegapung was not impressed
by this he does go on to say that there
were some things that he had wished he
had handed over to her he then goes on
to drop one of the big big questions
that came out of this chapter as
vagapunk says also Straw Hat Luffy it's
fated that you have come here can you do
something for me can you take me out of
Egghead so what do we think of that two
things come to mind for me firstly where
is it that vagapunk wants the straw hats
to take him you know it's one of the
island maybe or to meet up with a
revolutionary Army does vega pumpkin
know that he is a wanted man in the eyes
of the world government who are after
him and he needs to escape the second is
of course the possibility that vegapunk
wants to join the crew himself do we
think that vegapunk could potentially
become a new member of the straw hats I
guess there are pros and cons for this
one but it would be very interesting if
that was the case as always guys leave
your thoughts and theories in the
comment section Below on this one we
love reading them we then move on to the
coast of Egghead Island and we see a
ship with none other than cp0 on it who
says this is Cypher pole allow us into
the harbor the next panel continues
stating that we've got information that
jewelry Bonnie is heading to Egghead
Luchi then says she's an eyesore who
repeatedly escaped but we no longer have
any use for her right next time we meet
I'll definitely kill her interesting
thing that we also got here is that they
are all wearing masks they now all
appear as masked cp0 agents of of course
we did see these masks before but they
were just on the table as they were
talking in one of the previous chapters
but now they are wearing them which does
spark my interest we cut to shocker and
the guys with him who are obviously
alarmed by the news Pythagoras has just
announced in saying that it's a
government ship he continues to say that
it would be bad news if they knew what
we harbored pirates in here cp0 and
Lucci are on this ship Lilith is just
like yeah let them enter Rob Lucci is an
assassin right and uh yeah now we know
that she is the evil side of vegapog
here but does she really want Rob Lucci
and code come in him like we don't know
if there is an ulterior motive behind
this or maybe Lilith is just a little
crazy like that and is excited by their
presence and the prospect of what is to
come we don't know but it's a crazy
answer the straw Hat's reaction is the
understandable one in which is to panic
at again not what boy Sanji you know who
turns around to Robin and says Robin
don't you worry I'll protect you no
matter how many times it takes our boy
Sanji he is a true knight in shining
armor here shocker then says prepare to
intercept them decline their request to
the harbor so the presence of these guys
really does heat things up does it not
the potential for some big stuff to go
down and some interesting battles are
sure to come from this which matchups
would you love to see let's not forget
that Zorro and Brooke are still by the
ship so we may see something from them
too now we then move on to kamabaka
Kingdom with the revolutionaries as they
frantically inform to dragon that
something is happening to Kumar we see
that Kuma is certainly in a rush to get
moving as they question what is
happening and wonder if he is still
under Navy control as we can see Kumar
is desperate to get out of there and
seems triggered in into getting to a
particular destination as the
revolutionaries are all shocked and
surprised as to what is going on here so
where is Kumar heading I think it makes
perfect sense that he is on his way to
Egghead Island based on the recent
arrival of the CP zeros but Oda could be
throwing us a curveball here and Cuba
could be heading somewhere else we shall
see now the final panel shows Dragon
yelling what's the matakuma where are
you going and then we see a vancoth who
says just stay here from now on our
battle as the Revolutionary Army will
start so the Revolutionary Army is now
on the move this is super hype and super
exciting what exactly will their first
move be you know where are they heading
to First and who is going to be the
victim of their first move with it being
the Revolutionary Army we know that we
can only expect big things but man did
that get me excited I really really
really can't wait to see just what we
are in store for and that is it for this
week's chat there was a lot
a lot on in this one again
was another that was a
a conversation but it was a chapter that
was really setting things up for what's
to come next we were told at the end of
the chapter that one piece will be going
on a break next week which I imagine is
giving Oda time to drop a huge chapter
when it comes back the stage really
seems to be becoming set and I think
that we are in store for like an insane
treat upon its return what did you guys
think of this chapter and are you
excited for what comes next of course I
mentioned that one piece is on break
next week so hopefully you guys will
have goes and back for the next chapter
if so I just want to say a quick thank
you for having me over the past three
weeks it's been an absolute pleasure now
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more one piece reviews and
chapters don't forget to smash that like
button make this the video you subscribe
if you haven't and hit the notification
Bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece chapter
reviews and updates until the next
chapter or video drops feel free to
check out our huge and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on Dragon
an hour long video on Shanks all seven
yonko and much more link to that is in
the description and on screen now thanks
again for watching and we cannot wait to
see you in the next one till the next
time my friends take care of yourselves